sunday surprise draft i'm going to begin
with the bengals offensive line yeah
and uh it contributed to the victory
by cincinnati over the tennessee titans
i remember very vividly to my chagrin
sitting in this seat on thursday during
the pft pm chris sims unbutton joint
mega pix podcast saying what the hell is
wrong with vegas why are the titans only
five and a half point favorites they're
gonna go in there and beat the crap out
of the bengals this is ridiculous is the
lock of the week and of course the
bengals win it straight up
thanks to that 80 turnover in the
offensive line they got it together joe
burrow doing great things and the titans
defense not doing great things but that
offensive line to have that much of a
change from one week to the next due to
injury and and new guys joining the team
and just everything just kind of thrown
together on the fly they made it work
and kudos to them and kudos to the
bengals yeah no i mean unbelievable
really i mean great job by the defense
borough was phenomenal
you know third downs titans couldn't get
off the field burro just you know always
made a play on third down to keep it
alive made another big play on fourth
down at one point to where they gave him
enough time to move around back behind
the pocket on a fourth and four he makes
a big throw down the middle to t higgins
who's becoming his go-to guy so uh yeah
that was cool to see it really was and
i'm on the joe burrow bandwagon already
just the way him hang on a second before
you right before you go to your first
pick should they not trade aj green for
whatever they can get for him i don't
even should they not dump him today yes
i don't know why why not i mean again
what so what are they going to do
are they going to pay them like big time
money next year they're going to pay
them 18 and 20 million a year no i mean
no right so trade him
call green bay call some of these other
teams that need receivers whoever it is
but yes i would you know between boyd
mixon
burrow
t higgins that's a pretty damn good
right there i mean that that is and then
you could add to that more with the
assets you get in aj green and free
agency and whatever else it is but to me
that would be the play all the way mike
i'm with you there all the way
uh maybe at the point where you have to
pay some of his salary maybe frankly i
would think so get someone to take him
do it so what they they need to do it
build build the future let's be
aggressive cincinnati you got a
quarterback that could win you a super
bowl all right rams the mcveigh golf
blunders will be my sunday surprise i
don't know who to blame it on i mean
either way i didn't expect you know i
knew the rams were gonna go down there
and struggle and have a tough time
against brian flores and that defense
you know again that super bowl was that
super bowl 53 rams patriots
that was
you know there was a blueprint there as
far as an understanding that was flores
last game as a d coordinator with the
patriots understanding that but then
just expose goffin mcvay with the pass
protection stuff and i gotta think it's
more goth than mcveigh i do on those
plays but truly you know to make those
type of plays and make the rams look the
way they did and then the dolphins and
two would not even have to play offense
i mean just the way they won i think was
even more surprising and i got to give
them a lot of credit
yeah that really was a stunner as it was
unfolding it was like as you said flores
knew exactly what the rams were doing
and how to beat it and the rams had no
answer for it until it was way too late
next one for me
uh and and i say this because i hear you
talk about this dynamic all the time
yesterday i saw a video on twitter of a
guy who looks a lot like you but was
wearing glasses talking about this same
dynamic the 49ers run game and how it's
adjusted each and every week to meet the
nuances of the opponent and it always
works they had 52 yards rushing
yesterday what in the hell that was a
stunner to me i expected them regardless
of who's out there jerick mckinnon kevin
coleman to michael hastie hand it to
kyle use check have whatever receiver
happens to be on the field okay demo's
out here comes brandon iuke we'll give
it to george kittle we'll give it to
this guy nothing 52 yards total rushing
for the 49ers and it wasn't like a
blowout and they abandoned the run it
was a close game through the first half
they just couldn't get it going chris no
that was that was a big surprise big
surprise agreed i you know i i really
you know even without debo samuel and
you know they got the running back
injuries you just thought the way the
49ers offense have been rolling the last
few weeks and the way seattle's defense
has been played i thought too i thought
you know yeah seattle might win it might
be 37-34
the way the game was going whatever but
49ers moved the ball early had some
opportunities they kind of blew it on
their first few drives of the game to
kind of at least get the momentum on
their side and then that was it but good
signs for seattle i mean to be able to
do that
you know and now you're going to have
done carlos dunlap added to the
the fray and jamal adams back
and then they got you know their rookie
first round linebacker back in the fold
brooks from texas tech to where maybe
they can make some improvements on the
defensive side of the ball just become
respectable because i think that's all
they got to do
um
i don't even know why for my next pick
um
but i mean the chargers i always love it
when i always love it when you preface
it i don't know why i'm picking i don't
know why i'm surprised but i still think
i'm surprised about the chargers being
the chargers i mean the chargers just
out chargering themselves once again
24-3
against drew lock and the startup
broncos offense and a less than healthy
philip lindsay
and you got bosa and tillery and ingram
and all these other good defensive
players to talk about
and you let them come back and win that
football game i mean to me that was just
i don't even know where to begin i
really don't now justin herbert i
understand he made some mistakes but
okay he's a rookie he made a whole lot
of damn good plays too where they're not
winning if he's not making those plays
but you know just the chargers defense
to let up some of the big plays they let
up in the second half the big run to
phillip lindsey the two play 75 yard
touchdown drive where he threw desean
hamilton i mean just the way it went
down
um just still shocking and even though
we've seen the chargers do this
a lot over the last three years
well and we've seen it three times this
year leads of 17 or more people gone
they've lost all of those games that
they are in falcons territory they are
you do it in a super bowl now to clinch
it all right last one for me this one
comes from the raiders browns game we
haven't given the raiders a whole lot of
love josh jacobs had 138 rushing yards
he was the he was the difference he was
the guy who
you know take me out to the cold and let
me play some old school football right
there was one play where where he had a
attacker coming at him and he just he
just
popped him i mean that don't
don't come near me and if you do you're
gonna pay for it so josh jacobs was a
pleasant surprise and let me tell you
what we're talking about the raiders
real quickly we haven't mentioned this
and we need to trent brown yesterday
this story about the iv where they got
air in his bloodstream which can be
fatal it's a serious health condition it
creates an air embolism potential they
had to take him to the hospital derek
carr was freaked out about it after the
game he said we didn't know what was
going on john gruden downplayed it the
nflpa is already investigating but we
send our best to trent brown that was a
bad kind of a surprise yesterday second
time this year we've had a needle mishap
and we just hope trent brown is fine
they kept him overnight and hopefully
he'll be able to return to las vegas
today chris yeah hopefully that he will
but yeah that makes it even more that
much more impressive is what what the
raiders did yesterday running the
football that way i mean because trent
brown is
he's he's an um he's a bulldozer in the
run game so uh to not have him and still
do that that's very impressive
i i think the last thing i got to go to
here
is really
i i don't even know where i want to say
lack of gay would want to give dalvin
cook praise here or do i want to crap on
the packers for lack of being able to
battle up dalvin cook what's more
surprising to you
you know i i guess i guess i'm going to
give this dalvin cook either way is the
surprise four touchdowns yeah i mean
four touchdowns
the vikings had four touchdowns right i
mean just everything he did the way he
made the packers look you know run game
pass game was phenomenal and i just i
guess i'm surprised that yeah he was
hurt with a groin injury and he came
back and he was
totally tip top 100 and the best player
on most explosive player on the field
and really made the packers look silly a
number of times so that was a shocker to
me i mean the fact that he just ran
roughshod all over the packers defense
yes i did learned it first
on the second on the same day
once again said tote the line you at
least you you have proven you can be
taught
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports